es war eine aufregende nacht des
vereines spannende nach das war eine
dramatische nacht wir haben die worte
von donald trump gehört und vor allem es
war bisher eine nacht ohne klares
ergebnis wir warten noch immer auf die
antwort ob donald trump im weißen haus
im oval office bleibt oder ob er
abgelöst wird dort von joe biden und wir
haben in den letzten stunden einige
interessante dinge gehört ihr habt eben
über donald trump über sein wesen über
seinen charakter gesprochen stich vor
donald trump allein gegen den rest der
welt wir haben diese escala tiefe
sprache von donald trump gehört in den
letzten stunden die sprache seines
sohnes der vom totalen krieg gesprochen
hat donald trump der gesagt hat dass
diese war im prinzip gestohlen wurde
dass das amerikanische system menschen
krupp macht die eigentlich gar nicht
korrupt sind und da stellt sich
natürlich die frage wenn man donald
trump so sprechen hört ist das jetzt
wirklich donald trump allein gegen den
rest der welt oder ist es donald trump
mit der ganz schöne menge anhänger zu
denen er da spricht und da gibt es einen
interessanten punkt mit dem ich heute
einmal anfangen möchte wir haben in den
letzten tagen oft gehört aus den beiden
lager noch nie wurde ein demokratischer
kandidat von so vielen kandidaten von so
vielen menschen in den usa gewählt was
sie liebe zuschauer in deutschland aber
relativ selten hören und das wollen wir
uns hier auf dieser karte einmal
anschauen ist dass es mit dem phänomen
donald trump in keiner weise vorbei ist
sondern dass das phänomen donald trump
auch wenn er die wahl möglicherweise
verliert dass das phänomen donald trump
deutlich größer geworden ist wir sehen
hier klein
die zahl der poppele der sogenannten
poppeller wort wie viele absolute
stimmen hat donald trump bei dieser wahl
geholt wir stehen derzeit bei 69
millionen 655.000 186 69 millionen
bisschen aufgerundet knapp 70 millionen
menschen haben donald trump bei dieser
wahl gewählt ja es haben noch nie so
viele menschen einen demokratischen
kandidaten gewählt wie joe biden 73
millionen aber 70 millionen menschen
haben auch donald trump gewählt wie
viele waren das vor vier jahren 62
millionen
donald trump hat ungefähr sieben
millionen zuzustimmen seit vor seit der
letzten wahl vor vier jahren zugelegt 7
millionen stimmen und das zeigt
vielleicht ein bisschen das jetzt bin
ich aus dem bild gegangen vielleicht
kann dir
die einmal ganz kurz auf diese kamera
zurück zeigen und da sind wir wieder am
liebsten in die kamera 1 danke liebe
regie das zeigt ein bisschen dass dieser
eindruck der hier in deutschland
entstanden ist dass donald trump so
etwas wie abgemeldet ist dass donald
trump mit der art und weise wie er
politik gemacht hat in den letzten
jahren die wähler verloren hat davon
getrieben hat dass ich davon gelaufen
sind
es ist leider in keiner weise der fall
und die wahrheit ist dass ihm die wähler
hinzu gelaufen sind donald trump ist ein
mobilisierungs phänomen auf beiden
seiten donald trump hat für joe biden
der so gut wie kein wahlkampf gemacht
hat als anti phänomen quasi mobilisiert
deswegen unter anderem deswegen hat
dollar hat joe biden so viele stimmen
wie noch nie jemand zuvor geholt aber
donald trump hat auch für sich selber
mobilisiert wie nie zuvor und hat noch
einmal zu 2000 16 7 millionen stimmen
hinzugewonnen wir wollen uns noch etwas
anderes anschauen bevor wir zu den
hochspannenden zeigen kommen donald
trump hat in seiner pressekonferenz von
etwas gesprochen was er zu preschen
pauls nennt was meint er damit zu
preschen unter unterdrückung es um
fragen was er damit meint ist wir alle
das kennen wir wenn wir nicht so ganz
entschlossen sind wir alle menschen
wollen am liebsten zu dem lager gehören
was gewinnt zum sieger gehören und wenn
wir nicht so ganz entschieden sind gehen
wir dahin oder gehen wir dahin dann
gucken wir uns vielleicht an
wer hat denn die bessere chance zu
gewinnen und entscheiden uns dann für
den sieger das ist das was donald trump
mit zu crashen prozent denn bei den beim
bowling und darüber haben wir den
letzten tagen schon häufiger gesprochen
und jetzt habe ich mir das für sie
einmal etwas genauer angeschaut beim
bowling in den letzten monaten lag joe
biden dramatisch vorne wenn wir uns
jetzt einmal hier auf den bildschirm
schauen dann sehen wir die pauls von von
den tagen vor der wahl vom ersten
november und vom zweiten november und
was man hier sieht in dieser spalte
beiden +5 beiden +7 beiden +3 beiden +4
beiden +5 beiden +4 beiden +3 beiden +1
beiden +2 und so weiter und so fort sie
sehen dass der großteil dieser dieser
spalte hier ist überwältigend blau und
das bedeutet das dass pauling eindeutig
für joe biden aus gmund den wlan die
auch vielleicht noch unentschieden waren
gesagt hat joe biden will
dieses ding mit abstand mit abstand
gewinnen und dafür habe ich jetzt mal
einige time präzise rausgesucht die wir
uns anschauen wollen florida lautete das
pooling beiden und dass davon gehen wir
vom 2 november vom tag vor der wahl
tag vor der wahl eine nbc entschuldigung
eine reuters-umfrage beiden 50 und 46 in
florida einem wehr innern uns der battle
braun states denn es gibt jetzt schauen
uns das einmal an und sehen buch zu
großen teilen roth jahresergebnis 51,2
zu 47,8 noch einmal polling 50 für
beiden 46 wird das war es raus gekommen
ist war nahezu das umgekehrte ergebnis
gehen wir noch einmal hier zurück auf
der karte und gucken uns einen weiteren
bundesstaat an und zwar den bundesstaat
michigan den joe biden tatsächlich
gewonnen hat hier oben michigan aber wie
schaut es da mit dem polling aus hier
kann man sehen
52,5 zu 45 4
da waren die letzte umfragen 51 für
beiden 244 da stimmt die margin also
einigermaßen wir merken uns
entschuldigung ich war im falschen staat
daran liegt es dass das pooling hier
stimmt wir wollten uns ziemlich
anschauen michigan und nicht minnesota
eine sekunde gehen wir hier wieder raus
rein in den staat michigan rein in den
staat michigan und da sehen wir jetzt
dass die zeit doch etwas anders aussehen
beiden 50 48 das paul lincke hatte
gesagt beiden 51 44 also eine deutlich
größere martin und das ist genau das was
jumps preschen mit sieben punkten
vorsprung uneinholbar war joe biden an
weiter am tag vor der wahl laut den
umfragen in michigan das ergebnis
stellte sich heraus war dann am ende
deutlich knapper nämlich rund zwei
prozent also 2 prozent das ist innerhalb
dieser sogenannten margera war nicht
uneinholbar er war innerhalb der margin
of ra aber was schon mit zu preschen
ports meint ist die umfrage haben den
menschen suggeriert es bringt überhaupt
nichts mehr für donald trump zu wählen
und wenn man sich dann anschaut dass er
immer noch 70 millionen stimmen geholt
hat dann kann man sich ungefähr
vorstellen wie gewaltig die
polarisierung in deutschland ist und wie
gross das potenzial des vut potenzial
ist an dass donald trump sich jetzt
richtet so jetzt wollen wir uns
anschauen was heute nacht passiert ist
und das spannendste was heute nacht ist
passiert das wie gesagt wir haben immer
noch kein ergebnis ist der bundesstaat
georgia wir haben sie in den letzten 48
stunden in den letzten drei tagen häufig
gesagt georgia ist eigentlich ein staat
den die republikaner sicher für sich
geglaubt haben und der so etwas wie das
herz der republikaner ist unser kollege
alexander von schönburg hat diesen staat
mit dem herzen der republikaner
verglichen dass es in etwa so als würde
die spd bayern erobern
wir haben hier also das herz der
republikaner und wir haben es in den
letzten tagen häufiger gesagt ja erleben
derzeit das pacman phänomen wie pacman
nagt die stimmenanteile des jeweiligen
gegners weg und dieser pacman markt im
moment massiv am herzen republikaner und
um uns das einmal deutlich zu machen
wenn wir jetzt hier auf georgetown
bundesstaat georgia hier unten im
südosten der usa und uns das anschauen
dann sehen wir immer noch dass georgia
überwältigend überwältigend überwältigen
droht ist überwältigen droht hier
dass es aber in den bevölkerungszentren
in den bevölkerungszentren sehr sehr
blaue aussieht und das ist ein typisches
phänomen des gespaltenen amerikas wenn
sie hier das blaue seen und wir gehen
jetzt hier mal auf die voll details
dieser karte und schauen uns das etwas
genauer an
sie sehen hier das blau und wir schauen
uns jetzt hier die wert haben ich kreise
jetzt mal mit dem finger um das blaue
herum 78 prozent 73 prozent dran 65
prozent schon 68 prozent an
74 78 prozent überwältigende anteile für
trump in suburbane amerika in den
sogenannten vor stecken und sobald wir
dann jetzt gehe ich mit dem finger hier
hinein in die vorstädte 56 beiden 72
beiden 83% beiden also zwischen dieser
vorstand hier wo 74 bis 80% trampeln und
dem county in dem dann die stadt atlanta
zum beispiel liegt haben wir ein
umgekehrtes wahl verhältnis 83 prozent
zu 3 nach
hier in diesen blauen zentren sind die
stimmen in den letzten stunden
ausgebildet worden
hier ist übrigens die schöne stadt
orchester mit einem der schönsten
golfplätze der welt doppelt trompete der
gerne gewonnen liegt aber derzeit
deutlich sind mit 67,9 prozent und wenn
wir uns jetzt anschauen was hier
passiert ist in diesem blauen zentren da
hat in den letzten stunden die
auszählung die meist die auszählung der
meisten stimmen stattgefunden und was
dort passiert ist das werde ich ihnen
gleich zeigen ist absolut dramatisch
wir gehen noch einmal zurück auf die
nationale wahlkarte und wir haben es
eben gehört hier in georgia beträgt der
stimmen im herzen der der republikaner
hier in jersey beträgt der stimmen
vorsprung von donald trump auf joe biden
immer noch 650 650 stimmen nicht 650.000
6650 stimmen in einem bundesstaat hier
unten 650 650 stimmen in dem es um 16
elektra awards 16 elektra awards sind
hier zu vergeben und das sind ungefähr
fünf millionen stimmen abgegeben und es
geht um den hauchdünnen unterschied von
650 stimmt und was dieses pacman
phänomen bedeutet was dort in der
letzten nacht passiert es das will ich
ihnen noch mal hier verdeutlichen anhand
eines weiteren anhand einer weiteren
kleinen zeichnungen der unterschied den
tramp der vorsprung den donald trump auf
joe biden hatte war zu einem gewissen
zeitpunkt ungefähr dass 300 siebenfacher
der stimmen von des 307 fache des
vorsprungs sehen er jetzt noch hat
wir reden von ungefähr 200.000 stimmen
donald trump vorsprung hatte jetzt sind
es noch 650 stimmen also sagen wir mal
drei das ungefähr 300 fache dieses blatt
papier din a4 papier hat 297 mm also
sagen mal grob 300 mm der vorsprung den
donald trump hatte war also so kann man
sich das verdeutlichen die ganze seite
dieses blattes papier das war der
vorsprung den donald trump hatte das
gesamte blatt papier und das was donald
trump jetzt noch an vorsprung in georgia
hat ist das hier unten
ich weiß nicht ob unsere kamera das
einfangen kann oder ob wir das
mikroskopische kameras brauchen aus dem
vorsprung der dieses ganze blatt papier
war ist dieser kleine punkt hier unten
geworden und der trend geht ganz
eindeutig ja ich habe hier noch mal
zeigen dieser kleine punkt hier unten
das war der vorstellung von donaldson
das ganze blatt passiert ist ganze din
a4 blatt und jetzt ist es noch dieser
kleine punkt hier unten in georgia dem
herzen der republikaner und der trend
gegen die bundesstaaten georgia der ist
ganz eindeutig auf der seite von joe
biden und wenn sie sich jetzt anschauen
wollen worauf muss sich in den nächsten
stunden achten 253 stimmen für joe biden
253 wir erinnern uns 270 braucht man
also laut cnn brauchte nur 17 stimmen
hier in georgia gibt es 16 stimmen zu
vergeben damit wären nur noch eine
stimme entfernt von einem wahlsieg und
vor allem wenn der beiden georgia drehen
sollte dann hat er die tür zugemacht für
donald trump dann ist es nur noch ganz
ganz schwer absehbar und aus meiner
sicht wenn ich die karte ist richtig und
will nicht mehr
mathematisch zu errechnen wie donald
trump an diesem verhältnis an diesem
stimmverhältnis noch etwas so drehen
sollte das doch nur tom auf die 270
stimmen kann also wir merken uns es geht
um georgia eine sache die auch noch
wichtig heute zu beobachten ist ist
arizona in arizona ist es jetzt ungefähr
20 minuten vor 2 uhr morgen arizona
möchte am morgen neue stimmen melden und
wir gucken uns noch einmal arizona
anschaut da ist es denkbar knapp 50,1 zu
joe biden 48,5 von kempter wird aber
immer noch gezählt da sind bisher nur 90
prozent der stimmen reporter die
republikaner sind überzeugt dass sie
arizona gewinnen werden aber derzeit
vorne liegt
joe biden und sollte diese beiden
staaten in den nächsten stunden fallen
dann war es das dann gibt es einen neuen
us präsidenten und der heißt so beiden
aber dann wir haben es gelernt sind 70
millionen menschen richtig sauer und
damit zu euch zurück ins studio lieben
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren